والان ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس
حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
وسهلا بك وطبعا هذا التصعيد الخطير من حيث
التوقيت
وال الموقع الجغرافي الذي يحدث فيه ما
اهميته ليلى التوقيت هو هو يعني حرب غزه
اكثر من 100 يوم واستهداف القوات
الامريكيه في العراق وفي سوريا هو مستمر
والعدد اصبح كبير اكثر من
150 استهداف الشيء الجديد هو الموقع
الجغرافي يعني نتحدث عن داخل الاردن هذا
شيء جديد يعني من استهدف الامريكيين هو
يستهدف الاردن بالمعنى القانوني
اثنين وقوع قتلى واكثر من
34 جريحا وهذا يعني ان هذه القاعده او
البرج 22 لم يكن معدا للحر لانه اصلا هو
قاعده لوجستيه
للتنفس طي تنف وبالتالي هذا المركز هذه
منطقه عسكريه منطقه مهمه جدا بالاضافه الى
الحركيه وحتى ان سلاح الجو الاردني كان قد
استهدف المهربين والمخربين والمتسللين على
الحدود السوريه فاذا نحن امام يمكن مرحله
جديده هل ستكون فعلا تح نقطه تحول يعني
انا اشك في هذا الامر بشكل تقريبا يعني
مهم وكيف يفسر عدم التصدي امكانيه التصدي
لهذه الطائره المسيره التي وصفت بانها
كبيره
في منطقه حساسه كما
ذكرت يعني يعني هذا هذا يدل ان هذه البرج
22 لم يكن مهيئا او فوجئ حتى يجب ان نعترف
انه ليس هناك من دفاعات جويه كامله
100% يعني اليوم المقاومه واستهداف الداخل
اسرائيلي هناك اهداف صواريخ تصيب اهدافها
بدقه فاذا ليس هناك من شيء كامل 100%
بالمعنى الامني قد تكون مفاجاه وهي قربها
من قاعده تنفع من الحدود السوريه قد يكون
هناك بعض الاخطاء ولكن 34 جريح يعني لم
يكن هناك استعداد يعني عامل المفاجاه كان
شيء اساسي اليوم يجب ان ننظر بعد هذا
الحدث الى موضوع التقييييم وبالتالي كيف
سيكون الرد
الامريكي اذا اي العميد الياس هل هذا
التصعيد مقصود خصوصا كما يعني وصف فادي
قبل قليل وتحدث سامر المقاومه الاسلاميه
اعلنت انها قامت ب عدد كبير من هذه
الهجمات في السابق ولكن تاثيرها كان محدود
هذه المره التاثير كان مختلف اصابت في
مقتل هذا التصعيد برايك عسكريا
مقصود هناك احتمالين ليلى الاحتمال الاول
ان يكون هناك حريه حركه للوكيل يعني لهذه
المقاومه الاسلاميه وهي مدعوم من ايران
لنكن صريحين وايران تعترف بذلك وهم
يعترفون بذلك ان يكون هناك ك تصرف دون
العوده الى المرجع او المرجع يريد ان يرسل
رساله كبيره جدا كما ارسل رساله في
باكستان في بلوشستان
لماذا لانه اليوم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الهدف الاكبر في المنطقه هو عدم
التصعيد واداره الازمه او الحرب المدمره
الدمويه ل ياخذها جيش الاحتلال في غزه
وبالتالي لا تريد هذا التصعيد هذا الامر
يعطي لايران هامش من الحركه بشكل بكل كبير
كان تقول انا ادفع
و
واختبر الخطوط الحمراء لدى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بشكل مباشر مع امكانيه
الانكار على ان هذا الامر هو من بواسطه
الوكيل كيف سيرد الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انطلاقا من هذه من هذا المفهوم
الاستراتيجي للمنطقه قد يرد على هدف مهم
ولكن سيكون اقل من حرب ولكن اكثر من تصعيد
كما تعودنا عليه و السؤال ربما الاكبر
والذي يعني يطلب الاجابه هو اين سيكون
الرد ى اي درجه يعني الجانب ذكرت موضوع
يعني ان هناك توعد ولم يحدث تصعيد بالسابق
وهناك الانتخابات
ف هذان العنصران الى اي درجه
يحددان طبيعه ومكان الرد
برايك هناك ثلاثه امور يعني تحدثنا عن
الصوره الكبرى لا للحرب في المنطقه موافقه
الكونغرس ليلى هذا امر مهم وبالتالي سنه
الانتخابات ولكن الرد يجب ان يكون اقرب ما
يمكن الى الاذن الايرانيه والعين
الايرانيه كي تعرف ايران ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه جاده يعني لن يكون
الهدف اقل سيكون اقل من حرب ولكن اصغر من
تصعيد ويجب ان يكون ان يتناسب مع الحدث لت
م الرد على الامريكي وبالتالي ان يصل
مباشره الى الاذن والعين
الايرانيه اشكرك العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي من بيروت و